هي فكره جديده وبصراحه غريبه الناس تتحدث
عن شركه سعوديه تقدم راتبا اضافيه لزوجه
الموظف الناجح او لزوج الموظفه الناجحه
متساوي يعني الفكره قويه وهي جديده كمان
وتدفعنا اليوم لنقاش حول سؤال القديم
القديم زوجتك هل هي مسؤوله عن نجاحك او
فشلك وايضا زوجك هل هو مسؤول عن نجاحك او
فشلك القصه تصبح اكثر تعقيده اذا كانت زوج
والزوجه يعملان في مكان واحد العلاقه تصبح
اصعب اذا كانت الدوامات نفسها صعبه واذا
كانت الدوامات مختلفه كذلك صعبه
هذا الموضع تحديدا ان تكون العلاقه من
الاساس صحيه العلاقه ما بين الزوجين بحيث
تتحمل اي ضغوط محتمله وتتحمل اخفاقات
طبيعيه ممكن انها تحصل في مجال العمل قبل
ان نتحدث عن مسؤوليه الشريك عن النجاح في
الحياه لميس ابراهيم تطلعنا على
استراتيجيه النجاح الوظيفي مع الشريك
العاطفي اكيد في استراتيجيه ما هي
استراتيجيه انه وراءها كل رجل عظيم امراه
طيب وراء كل امراه ناجحه زي ما قالت رجل
عظيم قالت
انا عجبتني هاي المقوله تفضلي يا لميس انت
محقه يلا
اداره عمل مشترك مع رفيق العمر يمكن ان
يوطد العلاقه او ينهيها كثر مورو مدربه
علاقات تقترح بعض الاستراتيجيات لانجاح
الشراكه في العمل والمنزل اولا تشجيع
بعضكما البعض بدلا من التنافس ضد بعض
الغيره ممنوعه والدعم مهم انتما تلعبان
للفريق نفسه ثانيا تحديد ادوار ومسؤوليات
كل منهما واللعب على نقاط القوه من
المفترض ان يكمل كل شخص ما ينقص الاخر
ثالثا وقت العمل عمل ووقت العائله للعائله
يجب ان تلتزم بوقت محدد يوميا يمنع بعده
الكلام عن العمل رابعا علاقتكما الشخصيه
تاتي قبل العمل اذا احتاج شريكك الى
اهتمامك كل شيء اخر يمكنه الانتظار طالما
لم يكن ملحا اخيرا حدد الاهداف كفريق واحد
طبيعي ان تختلف الرؤى المهم ان الهدف واحد
على كل حال سال الناس من السعوديه ما دور
الشريك في تحقيق النجاح الوظيفي نتابع
الاجابات
الشريك تحقيق النجاح الوظيفي انه احيانا
يكون او غالبا يكون سبورت او دعم للمراه
اذا كان هو شخص ناجح ومحفز لها يعني في
الحياه بس عموما هو لازم يكون عنده هيئه
اساسا بذره او حاجه يعني بسيطه وهو يكمل
يساعدها هنا يكبر الدور اكثر والله شوف
اكيد
النبي دورها كبير يعني اولا بدايه من
المنزل يعني
ودعم الرجل وسبل الراحه اللي يلقاها في
البيت هذا الشيء بيكون انعكاس عليه في
عمله فهذا دور كبير وبرضو ما ننسى دور
الرجل اللي هو اهتمامه بالبيت
واهتمامه بالمراه وهالشيء انا اعتقد انه
متكامل
الدور اساسي الشريك اساسي معك
ارتياح في ترتيب الشو اسمه في الحياه
كامله نمط الحياه كامله
المشاركه حتى في تنسيق العمل تمام
واجبات البيت تمام
مناقشات في جميع الامور يعني
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا في الاستوديو نور ديره مشاريع
التميز رشا ابو غزاله اهلا وسهلا فيكي
ستراشى معنا في صباح الخير تفضلي طيب فكره
جميله جدا انا كتير عجبتني وعلى فكره يعني
مش لاني متحيزه على اساس انه انا اخذ راتب
اضافي من وراء
العمل الجيد لزوجي ولكن ايضا بالعكس هل
معنى ذلك من واقع عملكم انه هناك اشارات
عمليه وعلميه مؤكده بانه الموظفين اللي
بعيشوا باستقرار عاطفي في المنزل
يبدعون اكثر في العمل اكيد
دور المراه لا يقتصر فقط انها هي تكون ربت
منزل هي ايضا شريكه للرجل في اليه العمل
ايضا وجود الرجل ونجاحه في عمله هو عباره
عن معادله صعبه وراء كل رجل عظيم امراه
عظيمه المراه لها الدور الاساسي في توفير
البيئه المناسبه للرجل لنجاح في عمله وهو
ايضا عليه دور جدا اساسي في انه يوفر
هالشيء
للمرضين كثير بانه احنا بنحكي عن الرجل
على اساس هو الذي يعمل والمراه تقبع في
المنزل هناك في نسبه كبيره
من النساء العربيات بيعملوا سوق العمل عم
يرتفع كثير خصوصا في دول الخليج في الصحيه
احد ابرزها يعني عشان بس نكون منصفين
عشان ما تزعلش مني انت كمان انا ماني
زعلان لانه انا خلاص
خليني اتكلم انه اليوم المراه دائما ما
هذا الكلام اللي تفضلتي فيه حضرتك قد يكون
على المراه اللي مرتاح لكن اليوم ايضا
المراه عليها ضغط عمل
ومطلوب منها انجاز كيف يمكن ان نبني هذه
الشراكه الناجحه بين الطرفين كما هي في
المنزل ايضا في العمل هي تبدا من البدايه
حيث انه يكون في تفاهم بين الطرفين على
توزيع المهام في المنزل وايضا الى توزيع
الوقت واداره الوقت بحيث يستطيع الاسنان
التوفير والمعادله بين المنزل وبين العمل
الدعم النفسي الدعم المعنوي الاستماع
المناقشه اعطائها الفرصه واعتبار ان اي
نجاح يتحققه هو نجاح شخصي لها بالاضافه
الى انه نجاح ايضا للرجل اذا كانوا اذا
كانوا في مكان واحد ما راح يصير بينهم
غيره وظيفيه
ايضا نرجع للاساس
اذا لا ينقلوا العمل الى المنزل ولا يصبح
الجو جو منافسه بينهم يعني نستطيع ان نقول
يعني مشكله اذا كانت هي بالقسم يعني بقسم
الماليه ومعاشها عن معاشا عندها
المشكله لاله ولكن مش لالها طيب على كل
حال
رشا هل مثل هاي المبادرات بحيث انه المراه
وهي جالسه في بيتها لانها توفر هذا الجو
الاستقرار العائلي والعاطفي بتاخد معاش
على الاقل شهر هل مثل هاي المبادرات
عمالها بتحفز النساء تحديدا او الشريك
اللي اللي
للموظف اللي عم نحكي عنه انه يكون اكثر
كيف بدنا نقول تعاونا
حسابها
المراه سواء كانت هي عامله او غير عامله
هي دورها اساسي جدا ما بنقدر ننكر هذا
الشيء
الراحه النفسيه للرجل وابداعه في العمل
اكيد من من وجود المراه ودعمها له سواء
كانت تعمل او لا تعمل ففعليا يعني هي
عباره عن معادله صعبه ولكن مع التنظيم
والترتيب ومع التفاهم اكيد بيحصلوا على
هذا الاشي وهي مبادره جدا رائعه يعني احس
راح تحفز طبعا النساء انهم يوفروا هذه
البيئه
على الرجل يخلونا ينجز في عمله وبالتالي
يعطونه معاشي زياده يرجع بهذا المعاش الى
المراه وبالتالي يشتري لها بربع المعاش
هديه لا خلينا نقول بان الا وليين اللي
قبل كانوا يقولون الام هي خيمه البيت
والاب هو عمود هذه الخيمه فبالتالي
الشراكه بينهم يستظل الاولاد شكرا جزيلا
رشا ابو غزاله مدير مشاريع التميز
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات